- [Narrator:] Buried on the depth chart and left for dead.
- This blue jean baby is fixin' to scrap.
- According to my calculations, it's
time to kick some ass.
- [Narrator:} They were never the first choice,
but they are the last hope.
- We're losing starters
at an unprecedented rate.
- I will struggle at first but then ultimately avenge you!
- I call it ‘Operation Playoff Berth.'
The mission: manage the game and minimize turnovers.
- [murmurs:] Ridiculous/Impossible!
- IT CAN BE DONE!
- [Narrator:] Now these hired guns are back-up and running.
- It's a suicide mission.
But there's one thing I've learned:
It's better to die
a starter than live as a backup.
- What you got, kid?
- Time to let this cat outta the bag.
- Yeah,
I'm thinkin' I'm Flacc.
- No, no, no.
You can't make me.
- Come on, Zach. We gotta git-
- I SAID NO.
- I got a guy who can take care of a thing...
- [Narrator:] THIS DECEMBER...THE B-TEAM IS THE A-TEAM.
- Oh, yeah. We're gonna eat that W.
We’re gonna sting like a butterfly, and pop like a weasel.
We’re gonna go-
- Hold on to your britches.
We got to make one more stop.
- So, will you join?
- F--k you guys. No.
I'm a leading MVP candidate!
- [Narrator:] The B-Team.
and sometimes the C-Team.
- Oh, sorry Dobbs. You're out.
- It's impossible.
I can't get you to the playoffs.
- Playoffs?! Huh. I just need you to get us to .500.
- Ooh, that's tough too.
- DAMN IT, IT'S MY WHOLE THING.
MIKE TOMLIN GETS A WINNING RECORD.
SO JUST WIN TWO GAMES.
- TWO?!